hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to time or of hurry Tia I
still don't know if I'm pronouncing that
correctly but this is so far the third
game in the time or series Tim or maybe
but supposedly this one's very very
different than the other ones but should
have a lot of spooks and scares dear my
dear nephew if you're reading this now
know that I am long gone you're the only
one I can trust so I give you the old
house in my will you've known about my
experiments
I had a success I managed to create as I
like to call it a health potion it helps
to heal any person's wounds within
seconds of drinking it I hope you find
some use of it you can find them in the
basement along with my other experiments
some have not tested positively though
so I hope you won't get into any trouble
because of them take care my dear nephew
best wishes your Uncle Frank
ok thanks Frank this is last letter to
me his experiments must have killed him
I must find my uncle but you said he was
dead you literally did I just said this
but I don't have a very strong brain so
I'm going to continue down ok so the
thing about the time or games is that
obviously the graphics were really
simplistic in the other games and I
don't think that it's going to be any
different in this game but the thing
about the other ones
oh those Pontins are those podiums Oh Oh
as you walk into the basement you slowly
overwhelmed by the sense of a gas leak
you become dizzy and delirious having a
hard time remembering where you came
from a while you will hear you spot a
radio and some strange-looking labels
somehow connected by wires to some
batteries what little do you remember is
your uncle's will you must quickly find
a self potion before the gas kills you
Oh throw light bombs to see further drop
a radio to attract strangers in the
basement pick up potions with --use them
with C ok qre see I'll try my best to
remember that here we go oh hello I got
a part nyan oh this is very doom like
dungeon Oh am I just gonna be creating
potty ins or taking potty ins I mean
like the other time or oh the gas is
slowly choking the life out of me is
this what happened to Uncle Frank yeah I
don't know
well but I suspect that there might be
some deadly creatures in the dungeon
I suspect exactly
oh my time my time is not good I didn't
even see that I had a mini-map in the
top oh god do I have to go through all
the spiel again Oh God at least it's not
that bad
alright let's go I guess hot damn you
know optimization is an important thing
in games but let's try this again I
don't even know exactly what killed me
so like why do I just have light balls
in my pants
what am I just walking around with a
giant bucket full of light bulbs in my
pants or nevermind the bucket is my
pants I'm just walking in it that
doesn't seem good that killed me last
time
Oh top left is my health ah top left is
my health and the whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa radio take some of that okay
so top left is my health the other well
I don't like the sound of that I think
there might be some demons down here
watch which my Uncle Frank doing my
lovely uncle who never talked to me and
granted me a house that was literally
one bedroom on the top of a hill that's
impossible to get to and not near any
store to shop from what did my lovely
uncle that I loved so much you know I
hope I don't get into too much trouble
in this dungeon of nightmares me which
I'm going to play dungeon nightmares
virtue Oh was that
my out of I think of out of light balls
my bucket of light balls have run out
you what was that
hey don't be doing that think you can
you can get me huh huh don't you know
who I is I'm markiplier I'm the king of
these horror games you don't know
nothing about nobody if you don't know
about markiplier and his ability to take
on horror games it's like my thing it's
like my jam bro well you want to come
ask me huh you want to come after me bro
huh You Know Who I am huh please don't
come after me I'm really quite scared
very scared anybody anybody in the
darkness anybody oh I should watch my
mini-map it's actually kind of hard to
follow oh so I really am I'm out of
radios n mile I'm sorry dude I graduate
are you okay sorry sorry just getting a
little twitchy well that's an
interesting sound why don't you do it
again louder and farther away from me so
that I can hear it just the same but
you'll be farther away that's like you
hey what the hell is with that brah come
on why are you gonna be tangling with me
like that
yo don't hip down my hoop D I don't know
what that means I try I heard it on the
street once I haven't been outside much
okay so it is it is kind of like a maze
I guess I'm trying to glance at the
thing but I moved so quickly that's
impossible to follow what was that huh
somebody playing a violin over there you
know how I feel about violin players
oh it's the alarm for telling everyone
how good I am at this game in non dying
I sure love me so like I don't have a
lot to go on here I don't have a lot of
inspiration to talk about and it seems
like I could just follow this boo what
is that oh I got a thing I don't know
what I got but I got it it was gold I
only caught a glimpse of it it was very
quick and then it was gone just like
that
and I seem to have run out of lightbulbs
and I have no more radios but there's a
thing like me but it's totally okay
because I'm chill
I'm the chillest chill that I've ever
seen I'm so chill look at me look at me
whoa I saw something over there I saw a
spindly something kind of looked like a
Slenderman but I know he's been long
dead for years now he'll never make a
return ever ever seriously what kind of
basement is this what kind of uncool
Frank do I have to I don't even remember
having an Uncle Frank frankly huh
frankly get it yeah frankly but frankly
I don't even remember talking about
Uncle Frank I don't remember Uncle Frank
at family reunions I don't remember
Uncle Frank being anywhere in my life at
any point in fact I don't even remember
having a family at this point because
there's poisonous gas it's killing me
slowly
okay all right [ __ ] shouldn't gone down
that way how do I blinking what do I do
I don't even know what the gold thing
was that I got I mean I'm carrying it
around in my bucket it's surely not
light bulb maybe a radio no not not that
exactly not that I got a hold up stop
doing that hey stop it you're such a son
of a [ __ ] stop being an ass blasting
bag of dicks of DX
oh god I've gotten to the point where
I've already taken part in your day with
your frickin dick how about you go flash
someone else yeah creepy COO yeah that's
how I could go away I don't like you I
don't like you I don't like you you're a
floatie flu what are you what are you
even why are you trying to kill me huh
I'm the straightest chillest guy who's
ever been on the street and chillin
I saw Rocky once that I I know that when
you're on the street you just sing
around trash cans over lid on fryer I'm
not on fire
you
all righty then oh and did I mention who
Oh God
oh I failed finding my uncle no joke
where the hell would my uncle be there's
a cheapens here I looked at this before
I didn't know what they meant
Oh so apparently I woke in all the
creatures and there's a lost cat and has
earned all the achievements and find
uncle's grave
why is uncle's grave in his basement why
is he in the basement what did he bury
himself in the basement at the other
creature be like oh poor creator that we
probably killed also there's a gas leak
but that don't bother us
chug chug potion potion Oh we shall bury
him here we shall make sure that he is
interred in proper fashion oh oh it's
that is relative come come come a
symbols in a lot of baloney
I'm out of here I ain't going in that
house no more I can't go further there's
an invisible wall maybe around the back
I can just find uncle's grave and this
will be gonna vote hello hi I found a
cat oh goody goody gumdrops for me well
I can't take you with me because taking
you down to the gas volcanoes would be
horribly horribly bad of me to do oh hi
well oh I go very fast alright let's
give this another gooo I'm not gonna use
a radio and light bulbs or [ __ ]
because they didn't give me anything
what a load of crap you know what I mean
you know what I'm saying what a load of
pork what a load a [ __ ] cos hork you
know what I'm says 'ln
okay I'm trying to look at the map a
little better this time because the map
actually does tell me a lot of detail
about the environment and if I can find
like a some landmarks that I can
actually use then I should be fine going
forward I don't actually need to take
all these potions but it is good to act
as a landmark for knowing where I've
been already so if I can just use that
and the map at the same time then I
should be okay going fear word is the
key gonna help me if push you can't
gonna help me I mean it would be really
impressive if this is all randomized
which I don't know if it is hello who's
there who Jer who wants a sloppy kiss I
give nothing but sloppy kisses this
Rangers that's not what I do don't quote
me on that
so I'm going into a cemetery over here
dang this place is big like you'd think
that the upstairs with a little more
locked on what is that what is with what
is what is that I don't know what that
is I don't know what it do or whatever
apparently you do nothing
because I actually I highly doubt this
randomly generated because frankly you
know I not that I'm trying to belittle
the developers to said if this much work
went in the environment I don't know if
that much work would have been put into
the programming to make it randomized is
this a question it's not like an insult
to the developer it's just comparing
everything else to the level quality
that I've seen thus far you know what I
mean you know I'm feeling you know what
I'm saying you get me you feel me you
feel me don't feel me please don't feel
me oh whoa whoa whoa big guy big face
big face man well hey how's it going
there buddy yeah so if I can just find
the family coffin you know that the
uncle is like oh I'm dying
I must oh I am gonna die I saw you Oh
slipped past like a boss I think I don't
even think that was a challenge I don't
think he was actually anywhere near me
at that point okay so I think that was
in the same place so this is not
randomly generated which means that
everything must be in a set location I
think that's another monster waking up
cuz it said something about a Woking oda
monsters if i remember that correctly it
was specifically like that you lookking
Oh des monsters Oh dimanche jollywood
are awake
whoa whoa whoa ready to crown each other
some [ __ ] in the face Oh ready to go
slamming on your jugular with my kungfu
chops oh man I'll give it one more go
one more go one more go to find my uncle
we're gonna found my uncle what is the
like the logo in the beginning time or
other a TTL which I don't know what
means it looked very Christmasy for some
odd reason if I look on the map there is
an interesting landmark up here kind of
like a locked away area that looks like
just contained so is there something oh
wait a minute this is a false wall
there's something back there yeah false
wall eh well I ain't been tutored by oh
wait whoa okay you're very slow but I
still don't want it yeah okay damn it
I'm out of potent aah god damn this was
a mistake I'm gonna die I'm gonna die
from death poisoning from all the gooses
yeah thank you got it okay so this
appears to be a series of rooms that
didn't sound fun man why am I such a
potion shortage this time around so if I
can find in one of these something good
potent
yeah those noises don't sound too
friendly
start be something here there's gotta be
something here hello how's it going
buddy don't you know that I hate you
okay so is there anything in here nope I
gotta I'm trying to look in all the
rooms all the rooms the rooms it doesn't
seem to be oh whoa oh that was a chest
okay so I think I've been here looking
in these little alcoves before I'm
pretty sure anyway cuz I would've
remembered or maybe not this place is
very big and disorganized even though it
has a lot of open spaces I'm just an
idiot okay I have definitely been in
here I know that okay so if I cut
straight across then I might be able to
find something new again I still say
there's a false wall back there like
where I found the little alcove on the
map the map went forward but this did
not make it seem like there's something
hidden away kind of reminds me of like
earthbound music on the creepy levels
you know the creepy levels I'm talking
about
everyone knows creepy levels boop beep
boop be in my pants he poop yo chest Ian
alright I guess the good thing about the
light bulbs is that if I lay them down
they'll be there forever I'm never gonna
find him I'm never gonna find my uncle
oh god why I'll never find him I'll
never find my uncle the uncle that I
think I love so much and I knew all my
life maybe I don't know the gas is
really starting to get to me so I don't
exactly know what I know
I think I know is probably not ruin any
fest but there's a lot of repairing and
I'm having a good old time checking
these wonderful potions that probably
are the actual source of my demise well
yeah okay I'm doing fine how are you
doing mom
oh you look so good did you dress up for
me you fun guys
ah yeah way to go home and meet Maya
hello hi God you sneak up on me so
easily
huh you look goo be your little goober
Gabba I'm gonna call you boobie cuz you
gue band gab all day long that's all you
do just goo be Gabi serious it feels
like someone just randomly interspersed
oh hey goobie how's it goin Gabba goo Oh
got to be careful here oh hey how's it
going buddy I don't know what that means
but it's probably bad
okay so goobies around he's around a
corner here I want to get trapped I
would never want to get trapped the
pressures on I feel the monsters
crawling down my neck not crawling
breathe and there's the alarm I wonder
what it means
what does he
does it mean a mystery about my Uncle
Frank I think that's what his name was I
can't really remember at this point
because I stopped caring but I think
there's a mystery to be solved here and
I'm gonna get to the bottom of it or I'm
gonna end up dead which wouldn't be the
more likely case in this scenario but
before that happens I'm gonna make sure
that I take one of those bastards down
with me or probably not do that either
I'm prides gonna die horribly I brought
you to scream Leo hey whoa hello buddy
Oh wah wah wah wah wah wah you're new
you're really new I don't remember
seeing you you're spindly bastard why
don't you go eat a dong not that I have
one spare but I mean just go find one in
this basement if you don't mind I mean I
don't know I don't know make you work
don't and again what is with the red
thing is that just a random thing
they're supposed to scare me
hmm I'm reading your face okay I think
he's about the goodest garment come at
me bro come on inhale Madonna all right
I failed it find my uncle but somehow I
feel more accomplished for just stopping
so that was time Oh our alpha vitia it
was a different experience from the
other time Wars but frankly I think I
kinda liked the charm of the other ones
more it was very typical in the
jump-scares of what the original games
did but at least jump-scares were
they're plentiful and annoying which in
those three mixtures sometimes you get
magic but this one was not bad so thank
you everybody so much for watching check
out the other time or animators that
were made both other games were animated
by cranbersher if they're absolutely
amazing and also I'm wearing my king of
the squirrels shirt it's a new shirt
that's on sale right now there's a link
down the description and all procedural
proceeds but a portion of the proceeds
do go to charity for Doctors Without
Borders so if you want to buy a cool
shirt that's got a marvel our hero thing
I think there are 20 bucks on the store
so checking out through the link there's
only a limited amount they will sell out
soon so thank you again everybody for
watching and as always I was
you in the next video
thank you